Halloween is well on its way and if you
want to honor the creepy holiday by
playing a truly terrifying video game
then I've got you sorted as was the case
with my list of terrifying video game
monsters there are so many different
games that have taken the horror genre
by storm while your choices are totally
dependent on what it is that freaks you
out here are four of my picks
I'm going to get this one over and done
with early because you know it's coming
amnesia the Dark Descent amnesia is one
of the most terrifying modern survival
horror games much like the early Silent
Hill games amnesia succeeds so well in
part due to its pacing and constant
feeling of vulnerability this produces a
genuine fear of having your protagonist
die horribly which keeps you tense and
alert particularly since all you can do
to avoid that grim fate is the hope you
can run and hide better than the
monsters can seek you out and he does
the kind of game that you can't forget
you know even if you'd thought of like -
if you've experienced all amnesia has to
offer and you're after something a
little more obscure you could try your
hand at five nights at Freddy's
five nights came out only a couple of
months ago you're a night security guard
and monitoring a number of different
cameras in the fast food joints
throughout the evening you need to make
it through the terror filled night where
you're being threatened by a number of
large animatronic animal characters who
advance on you slowly hour by in-game
hour your one defense against that is
the foresight to shut the door to your
room before they get you
the gameplay is so simple you wouldn't
expect it to elicit much of a scare
although the problem is using the
cameras lights and door that are
available to you spend power a limited
resource that when exhausted leaves you
totally vulnerable and liable to jump
eight feet out of your seat when you're
inevitably attacked in a sudden jump
scare resulting in the end of your game
one of the most dreadfully terrifying
games I've had the misfortune of playing
is siren blood curse this PlayStation 3
game is seriously violent and throws you
into a cursed village the worst part of
the whole ordeal however is also
supposed to be your greatest asset that
is the ability to look through the
freaky usually bleeding eye holes of
your enemies and sight Jack them to find
out exactly where they are
this can be super handy but quickly
turns horrifying when you can actively
watch an enemy bear down on your hiding
spot reveal you and tear your little
pieces the monsters are twisted and
mangled reanimated corpses and there's
far more running and hiding than there
is taking advantage of the game's
weapons and facing your foes head-on as
you can probably tell identified horror
games more successful when they make you
feel particularly vulnerable this can be
achieved by limiting save points having
your protagonist be a dainty schoolgirl
or equipping them with only a camera or
all of the above
fatal frame throws a bevy of jump scares
and ghosts at you from every corner of
the dev team's nightmares and it's
insanely effective the most effective
way to attack yours is to hold up your
camera and wait till they're at their
most horrifying which is usually when
they're right up in your grill then and
only then can you snap a shot for
maximum damage and prey is enough to
knock them back your enemies range from
little ghost girls reaching out at you
to blind monks reanimated corpses
witches and all kinds of horrifying crap
unluckily for those of you who are
skittish the delivery of the series is
also very horror movie-esque that is
filled with cutscenes that go all out on
the jump scares so there's no time to
relax even when you aren't gripping the
control of a survival if you're lucky
enough to find yourself in Japan with
the ability to read the language you
might also be interested in facial frame
Oracle of the sodden Raven for Wii U
which came out in that region
exclusively last month
let me know down in the comments which
game you think is the scariest ever
particularly if it's one I didn't
mention be sure to have yourselves a
wonderful Halloween and I will catch you
and soon